bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti prossimo
video sono bravi j
oggi siamo su io sono un pane in panne
si è stato lo stesso team di sviluppo di
san joan simulator ragazza quindi
andiamo impersonale ragazzi una fetta di
pane ok facciamo ivy è diviso in giorni
pure facciamo monde mancava al
simulatore del pane sarà un quasi tutto
tranne questo quindi bene così became a
tosto come dovrei giocare a quest'ora
baragalla penso di dovermi tagliare
invece no io sono già vivo cioè non sto
capendo cosa sto faccia i coming attimo
devo premere due
scusami eh non volessero sbagliato
ragazzi che come il cazzo ci non sarà
anche fare due passi sta roba bellissima
ho capito perfetto l'agenda no però
quando smetterà di romperle cosa ce l'ho
fatta un attimino a capire come ci si
muove anche se è vicinissimo anche se
non sembra iniziato chi no
ok va bene non fa non fa niente non fa
niente cos'è uno skateboard che figo
sono sullo scotch è perfetto regata
adesso siano salvi dalla sporcizia è
perché prima era sporca adesso no ecco e
non è il vero che si muove anche lo
skate non c'è proprio figlio devo ancora
capire di preciso come ci si muove a
rega perché ancora non ho capito niente
io devo distruggere qualsiasi cosa ma
posso giocare anche senza mouse kobe
oddio mica che saltò fatto capire su
cosa più semplice calzolai vai vai vai
vai vai vai vai attaccate mio dio come
fisicamente possibile questa cosa
i prezzi
no kat adesso ragazzi adesso pretendo
una suite no qualche altro ho capito
perché stavo cadendo c'era normale
perché c'è la scritta grip in alto che
quando arriva lo 0 poi caschi c'è un
macello
sì l'ho presa bye bye bye bye bye bye
cosa ma davvero ma serio una fetta di
pane fa cadere una seriamente anche un
metro c puoi farmi qualche non ci credo
se cioè il 45 minuti pasta merda ragazzi
ma se ti lo schiaccio gli scarafaggi
costa roba dai cazzo fammi vedere di che
pasta sei fatto di che farina 6 fatto
quello che è eccolo eccolo se lo prendi
olio mancati tutti gli scala fare in
compenso abbiamo abbiamo dei cerali
digeribili per colazione a me almeno
quello dove ha fatto arrivare sul frigo
non lo so neanch'io fermi natio dio no
no no no no no no no no è [ __ ]
sono morto di brutto proprio forse no
forse lo sono ma no sono morto da tempo
la nave sono leggermente sotto a mangerò
questo post ok va bene guarda anch'io ha
sì sì sì sì sì la stoffa c'è
calmi ho fatto è stato tra cosa stesso
no no no non sa cos'è quella terra di
mezzo non va bene o giusta non faccio in
freezer come un toast devo fare una cosa
a james bond adesso scusatemi un attimo
pro devo si ok ok troppo propri ragazzi
è stato è veramente tragico riuscire a
portare avanti stop è difficilissimo non
sembra ma no di quella moda
sì sì l'ho fatta no la faccio ok mi
piaccio massimizzando rotto anche una
tazzina
vabbè ma capisco perché se vado a terra
mi sporco ma se la do sul muro no poi
mai noi vai vai sì sì solo mezz'ora per
falsa parte lega al macello che poi che
cosa c'è qua sopra un cazzo mi sta
inglobando una bacinella regala non ho
capito perché sto facendo ste robe però
va bene
ragazzi devo arrivare al tostapane
allora adesso devo devo lanciarmi sarà
difficilissimo ma ci provo
si no sì l'ho fatta
che botta di cui posso prendere un
coltello no kat
adesso sono solo un pezzo di pane armato
quindi attenti a chi sfidate complimenti
per questa cosa stupenda fatemi andare
un attimo al tostapane perché eccoci
minchia siamo a casa ragazze ci ho messo
80 minuti ad arrivare il codice non
poteva metterlo vicino al pe al no
d'altra parte della stanza lei entra
entra stronzo ma può entrare cosa fa
toasting non puoi costarmi sono sono
dentro un ragazzo è possibile da guerra
c'è ma guarda che è merda che fossi come
ho fatto
non vi preoccupate perché lo so che io
vedo preoccupati state sudando pro ci
faremo e la roba nuova madre tostata
credo che l'obiettivo sia quello di
tostare il pane ragazzi quindi quando ho
finito di tosta del pane ho vinto il
problema è che non se la sto facendo
perché mi è caduto che se se grazie a
dio ci ho messo che poi non sono i
ragazzi come tostate il pane però io non
lo so mai così a pensavo di costare solo
un pezzo vabbè dai ma è buono anche così
quanto siete pignoli ma il mio dio va
bene anche così no no no no no no no no
no non ti ammazzo la famiglia porca la
put si sono ancora in piedi ma andiamo
si si fa chiara ce l'abbiamo fatta
ragazzina è stata alien ma tosto press
space adesso che succede
ho vinto ho vinto fantastico pec come
come come fa vj ovviamente come voto
centosessanta minuti di orologio per
fare un toast della madonna
grazie grazie mentre pregava che minchia
che disastro allucinante ci ho messo è
stato un parto ceramente un parto io
voglio vedermi in porto simulator prima
o poi lo faranno sicuro e la roba
allucinante giorno 2 lange possiamo
farlo adesso sia un nuovo figo abbiamo
cambiato location procede alla
televisione
fatevi accettare facciamo un po di pane
tv vai vai perché solo con la marmellata
lento st pani in questo dove devo andare
per postare mi muovo nati o perché sono
riesco niente e devo distruggerle che
abbiate pazienza ma io ci provo
cosa ho fatto non ho toccato terra vai
così erano piano piano bello e
bellissimo sale niente sono caduti sono
spider man o non è che io sto panino lo
nomino un nuovo spider man
voglio un film su questo se lo fate le
tra voce e pieno e con la colla
l'accordo vorrei un po di colla sul
panino
vi ringrazio mi metto anche la fetta di
pane nel portapenne perché faccio ne
rendo quando proprio non mi vedo non
aiuta la verità anche voi fate merenda
quando non mi vedono i prof
vai vai vai vai vai vai cos'è ho buttato
giù skate slancio incredibile non c'è
più lo skateboard però un cazzo è finito
credo di dover andare su termosifoni
oddio no no no no no no cazzo motto che
hanno toccato terra neanche a deco mi ha
fatto andare sotto il tavolo si è caduti
in avanti
bye bye bye bye bye dai che ce la posso
fare no perché muoio prima voglio prima
da avon
no no no no non è ecco perché quello che
non doveva succedere successo è una
tardi solita [ __ ] nissan
intrappolato da solo ben bellissima sono
un genio
dai forza si cosa ho fatto
voglio replay di questa roba subito non
ho capito bene come ho fatto ma va bene
così erogano non è un problema come
magari non è neanche non è neanche il
termosifone e la soluzione c'è una vera
non muoio serio solo vivo non sono morto
sollevo [ __ ] [ __ ] mezz'ora
di tempo buttato affanculo fantastico no
no no no no che mi sta crollando tutto
posso sapere questo senza che crolli
tutto no no vero ecco lo sapevo
ragazzi ho fatto una [ __ ] sottiletta
fontana mia prima ci togliamo d'asta
mera ecco perfetto ma la palla che non
c'è un cani stop credo è sacrosanto
questo momento se riesco invece no si no
io mi uccido in modo violento orcadi
quella troccola troppo e quella portami
senza tipo in assassin's creed da qua
sopra però leggermente difficile ecco
perfetto qualcuno dove è morto pace
all'anima sua
bikemi ovvio che tattica ragazzi sta per
statiche bellissimo vai forza veloce
veloce ci siamo quasi
ci sono quasi non mollare non mollare
non mollare non noi quando è caduto un
quadro me ne frega un cazzo sono in
panne e nessuno mi può denunciare si è
già fatta e messo delle fottute oren io
devo uccidere per forza la marmellata si
è fatta ed è qua che devo andare per
però non come l'as caldo non ho capito
non era questo il punto dove devo andare
e poi polvere ma legame l'attacco perché
tanto non livello che se cade a terra
che si sporca il muoio però se prendo da
polvere dai mobili o immobili va bene
con me è commestibile quella ok devo
andare a prendere la palla da bowling
che stava sa perché se no che non devo
neanche eto'o star mi devo muovere la
palla da bowling time all'inizio sono
questo è arrivato ma guarda lì ce l'ho
fatta ce l'ha fatta perfetto perfetto
devo buttare giù la palla no cazzo come
cosa dove cazzo fai
ok ok eccoci che ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatto che tanto devo fare strike
nokia buttati giù i birilli e successo
esploso tutto no oh mio dio o fu il suo
televisore bello
quaterna fermi nativo fuso tutto
seriamente dovevo bruciare il televisore
e tostare il pane sul televisore
certo io io non so perché nella vita
sono stato affascinato da assassin's
creed a metal gear halo quando c'era
questo che più bello può altrimenti
perché porca [ __ ] non so come ho fatto
a non accorgersi prima di questo
capolavoro videoludico è leggermente
bruciato sto tosto prova beh è già
qualcosa perfetto cento per cento
sono un tosto f come fa vincere di nuovo
fantasma non è ormai mi conosce il gioco
lo sai che sono bello abbiamo ancora da
fare tra l'altro ce ne sono
casini che sono 7 ecco perché abbiamo
bedroom la prossima manovra ma fatemi
solo vedere come butto sul quadro nella
partenza e bellissima comunque ragazzini
ora il modo di come si fa a vincere
questo livello poi vedremo belli calzini
per dovevo nel prossimo episodio ragazzi
comunque conclude qui il video ci tengo
a dire che questo è stato uno ai
videogiochi che mi ha colpito di più nel
profondo da quando gioco e videogames
perché questo è bello proprio ti dà la
voglia di dire cazzo stamattina rialzo
riprovo la mia esperienza suprema su aim
brad con un bellissimo brad pitt tutti
ragazzi concluso il vile episodio su aim
brad non ti verrà nei prossimi episodi
come se i ragazzi se il video è piaciuto
momento mi piace anche a passare
facebook e come l'attività tra tedeschi
zione cioè se vorresti di silente che ci
vediamo un po se unito belle ragazze
[Musica]